القطيعه المصريه الايرانيه بدات عام 1980
بعد عام من الاطاحه بالشاه محمد رضا بهلوي
اسباب القطيعه ايران تحججت بتوقيع مصر
اتفاقيه السلام مع اسرائيل واستضافه شاه
ايران محمد رضا بهلوي
وبالنسبه لمصر في ايران اطلقت اسم خالد
الاسلامبولي المتهم باغتيال السادات على
احد شوارع طهران ورفع جداريه ضخمه تحمل
صورته
محاولات التقارب عام 2003 الرئيس المصري
حسني مبارك يلتقي نظيره الايراني محمد
خاتمي على هامش قمه دوليه في جنيب
عام 2012 زياره الرئيس المصري محمد مرسي
لطهران لحضور فعاليات قمه دول عدم
الانحياز
عام 2013 الرئيس الايراني محمود احمد نجاه
في القاهره لحضور قمه منظمه التعاون
الاسلامي
وفي عام 2022 الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي التقى في بغداد بوزير خارجيه ايران
حسين امير عبدالله يان
وفي عام 2023 وزير خارجيه ايران يشير الى
مباحثات لتحقيق التقارب بين القاهره
والطهران وبرلماني ايراني يؤكد الاتفاق
على اعاده فتح السفارتين بين البلدين
قريبا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات